وينضم إلينا الآن وزير الخارجية
المصري سام شكري الذي كان
سفير مصر هنا في الولايات المتحدة
قبل بضع سنوات، وذلك عندما
التقيت به لأول مرة، وزير الخارجية، شكرًا جزيلاً لك
على قضاء بعض الوقت
وإطلاع مشاهدينا على آخر المستجدات.  ما الذي يحدث
ما الذي يحدث بالضبط عند معبر الرفاع الحدودي
جنوب قطاع غزة بين
غزة ومصر في الوقت الحالي هناك الكثير
من الجدل حول ما يحدث،
موقف مصر من السماح
للأمريكيين الفلسطينيين بالمواطنين الأمريكيين الذين
يحاولون الخروج من غزة بالدخول إلى  عبور
تلك الحدود إلى
مصر أوه، شكرًا جزيلاً لك على استضافتي
ذئبًا أردت توضيح بعض
المغالطات أه في مقالتك قبل أن يتم
فتح معبر رع رسميًا على
الجانب المصري وكان مفتوحًا طوال الوقت
والمشكلة التي ظهرت هي أنه
أه  تعرضت أه لقصف جوي
وبالتالي في جهة غازين الطرق
ليست في حالة تسمح
بعبور أه المركبات
وكذلك أن القائمين على
جهة غازين يرون أنه من الضروري
إذا أه مواطنين ثالثين  ليخرج
أنه من الممكن دخول البضائع الإنسانية
ولم نتمكن من الحصول على أي
تصريح لأه إرسال
الإمدادات الإنسانية لتخفيف الضغوط على
غزة حتى الآن المعبر على
حد علمنا لدينا
الكثير  من الطلبات التي نقوم
بمعالجتها وقد أشرنا إلى أننا
سنقدم كل التسهيلات والمساعدة
أه نحن في تعاون وثيق
مع أصدقائنا الأمريكيين أه إدراكًا
لأهمية هذه المسألة ليس فقط
للأمريكيين لك الكنديين
للمواطنين الثالث من هولندا
من النمسا لذلك هناك عدد كبير جدًا
أه يجب عليهم الحصول على إذن
من جهة غازين للعبور وكما
ذكرت أه المعبر نفسه من
جهة غازين غير صالح للعمل بسبب
القصف الجوي لذلك أساسًا ما أسمعك
تقوله أه وزير الخارجية  هو أنه
إذا تمكن مواطنون أمريكيون أو مواطنون آخرون من
دول أخرى من الوصول إلى معبر رفح
الحدودي من غزة إلى مصر،
فسوف تسمح لهم أه بالدخول إلى مصر، فهل هذا
صحيح إذا كانت جميع الإجراءات قد
تم اتخاذها واجبًا، فقد تم التحقق من
وثائقهم أه  بالنسبة لهم في
موقع غازين للعبور ومسموح لهم
بذلك سنقدم لهم كافة
التسهيلات بالتعاون مع
سفاراتهم لإيصالهم أه إلى
نقطة انطلاق أه حتى يتمكنوا من العودة
إلى بلدانهم الأصلية فإذا
افترضنا  أن المواطنين الأمريكان يمكنهم المرور
عبر معبر رفح الحدودي إلى
مصر في سيناء من أين يذهبون من
هناك سيكون هناك مركبات حافلات سيارات
يمكن أن تأخذهم عبر شمال سيناء
وسيتم التنسيق مع
سفاراتهم لتوفير وسائل النقل لهم
وأنهم سوف أه يفترض أه
حسنًا، سيجدون رحلات طيران للعودة إلى ديارهم،
لذا هل سيذهبون إلى CYO، هل
سيذهبون إلى أين سيذهبون في
سيناء، ربما سيتم النقل
عن طريق البر إلى القاهرة ومن مطار القاهرة
فصاعدًا إلى وجهتهم النهائية
ولكن  في الوقت الحالي ما تقوله وأنا
أريد فقط أن أكون دقيقًا يا
وزير الخارجية أنت تقول الحدود أه
المعبر مفتوح بالنسبة لمصر،
أنت على استعداد لقبول هؤلاء
المواطنين الأمريكيين وهؤلاء المواطنين الآخرين إذا
استطاعوا  وصلنا إلى هناك ولكنك تقول
أنه بالقرب من المعبر الحدودي في رفح
بسبب القصف الذي يجري
من قبل الإسرائيليين على الأرجح، وأنهم
لا يستطيعون الوصول إلى هناك، هذا ما
تقوله أنا أقول أن أه
المعبر الحدودي في غزة  الجانب غير صالح للعمل
بسبب الأضرار التي
لحقت وأه الإجراء الذي يقوم به القائمون على
إدارة الحدود من جانب غزة للتحقق من
الوثائق وقوائم أه
الرعايا الثالث التي تم تقديمها
أه لم يتم ملؤها أه حتى أه حتى
الآن  بما أننا معنيين أه أشرنا
مرارا وتكرارا أننا سوف
نسهل نحن بالتنسيق مع
السفارات في القاهرة لاستلام
قائمة الرعايا الخاصة بهم وبالتأكيد عند
خروجهم وكما يتم
استيفاء دخول أه  المساعدات
والإمدادات الإنسانية أه سيكونون
سعداء للغاية بمواصلة تسهيل
العودة إلى بلدانهم الأصلية وهي
الإمدادات الإنسانية أه الموجودة
في مصر الآن قادرة على المرور
عبر معبر رفح الحدودي إلى
غزة لمساعدة الفلسطينيين الموجودين
هناك أه  لا للأسف لا أه نحن
ننسق مع الأمم المتحدة
مع أونا أه للتقدم بطلب
السماح بعبور الإمدادات
عبر معبر رفح
وإيداعها لدى الأمم المتحدة
لتفريقها لكن لم نحصل أه على
تصريح بذلك لذلك نحن  أه
أعتقد أن الظروف صعبة للغاية
مع كنت أتحدث للتو مع
مدير أه أه اليرا الذي يخبرني
أنه لا يوجد ماء ولا
كهرباء ولا إمدادات
ولا توجد مساكن
لجموع الناس  الفلسطينيين الذين
نزحوا من شمال
غزة لذلك الوضع أه حرج للغاية
ونود أه بشدة أن
نوزع جميع الإمدادات التي
وصلت إلى العريش في أسرع وقت ممكن
لتلبية أه احتياجات هؤلاء
الفلسطينيين المستضعفين الذين هم  أه أه في هذه
الظروف الصعبة للغاية كما تعلم يا
وزير الخارجية وزارة الخارجية الأمريكية
نصحت جميع المواطنين الأمريكيين الذين ما
زالوا في غزة الآن إذا أرادوا
الخروج أن يذهبوا إلى ذلك المكان القريب من معبر
رفح أه الحدودي إلى مصر
للوصول  أقرب ما يمكن الآن أن
يغادروا إلى مكان آخر في غزة ويحاولوا التوجه
جنوبا نحو معبر رفح الحدودي
أه هي
فكرة جيدة أنا حقا لا أستطيع التعليق على
ما هي الظروف وأه ما هو
التقييم الأمريكي أه  من درجة
الأمان التي يمكن توفيرها أه
لمجموعة كبيرة أه كبيرة من
الرعايا الأجانب أن المعبر الحدودي إذا
لم يكن قد أنهى
إجراءاتهم للعبور فعليا لذلك أه
سأترك ذلك لمن قد يكون  مزيد من
المعلومات حول الوضع الفعلي على
الأرض يا وزير الخارجية في
محادثاتك مع نظيرك الأمريكي
وزير الخارجية الأمريكي توني بلينكين،
ما هي خلاصة
الرسالة التي ترسلها مصر إلى الولايات المتحدة في الوقت
الحالي، حسنًا، لن أضعها في سياق
أ  خلاصة القول أننا كنا في اتصالات لقد
تحدثت مع السكرتير يومض
أه يوم السبت في وقت مبكر جدًا وكان
لدينا اتصالات مستمرة بين الوزارتين أه أه
وزارة الخارجية ووزارة
الخارجية وغيرها من
الجهات المصرية المختصة أه نحن
ندافع عن أه  الحاجة إلى احترام
القانون الإنساني الدولي أه
الحاجة إلى معالجة المخاوف
والظروف أه الصعبة للغاية التي
يعيشها المدنيون الفلسطينيون نحتاج إلى
حماية أكبر أه
للمدنيين حتى لا يتعرضوا أه لإطلاق النار
وبالتأكيد أعداد أه ارتفاع
الضحايا  أه وإصابات مع أكثر
من 500 طفل لقوا حتفهم أه
خلال هذا الصراع نحن بحاجة إلى
احتواء هذا ونأمل أن نرى مخرجا
من المستنقع والعودة إلى
التعامل مع مسألة حل
الصراع الإسرائيلي الفلسطيني
و  انتهاء الاحتلال هل ترى أي
أه حل سلمي ينشأ أه في
أي وقت قريب مما يحدث في
غزة الآن لأنه من الواضح أن
الإسرائيليين يستعدون لغزو بري واسع النطاق
لمحاولة تدمير حماس
في
غزة حسنًا نحن متفائلون دائمًا
ونحن كذلك  أدعو دائما إلى أه أن يعم السلام
في المنطقة
لإيجاد الحل على أساس
الشرعية الدولية
والإجماع الدولي على
حل الدولتين أه الظروف الحالية
طبعا أه لا تساعد كثيرا على
معالجة ذلك و  وبالتالي نحن
نركز الآن على حماية
المدنيين واحتياجاتهم ونأمل
في احتواء هذا وأن نكون قادرين على العمل بشكل
أكثر فعالية بالتعاون مع
الولايات المتحدة لأه إيجاد
حل نهائي للصراع. من الصعب
القيام بذلك بينما  هناك نشاط عسكري
جاري أه لكننا أه نعتقد أنه
يتعين علينا التعامل مع جميع
الجوانب المختلفة هل أدانت مصر
هجوم حماس الإرهابي على إسرائيل الذي وقع
قبل أسبوع لقد كنا واضحين جدا أننا
لا نقبل أي شكل من أشكال الاستهداف
المدنيين الأبرياء قلنا ذلك في
تصريحاتنا العلنية وقد قلنا ذلك في
القرار الصادر عن
الجامعة العربية وكانت إحدى القضايا
التي شددنا عليها وما زلنا نعتقد
أن جميع الاهتمامات يجب أه أن
تتوافق مع القانون الدولي الإنساني
و  تجنب أي انتهاكات جسيمة أو
ما يمكن اعتباره جرائم ضد
الإنسانية